chief Washington correspondent major
Garrett is also watching the Democratic
race going into Super Tuesday major good
morning good morning who has the most to
gain from Pete booted judges exit in
theory Joe Biden but as it O'Keefe
pointed out back in January the second
choice for most Budaj edge supporters
was Elizabeth Warren but that was in
January things are different now and the
Democratic Party is looking to
consolidate Joe Biden is the person most
likely to get that consolidation metric
or that idea but this is the real key
for the Biden campaign it has got to get
better faster it's got to take this
momentum from South Carolina add the
Buddha jet supporters and donors if it
can remember as Joe Biden was winning
South Carolina his number one endorse of
their Congressman Jim Clyburn said his
campaign had been mishandled what did he
mean by that he meant that Joe Biden was
probably always going to win South
Carolina and win it big but what that
victory did is saved by dn't Astra fee
it did not catapult him into the
absolute undisputed frontrunner position
why because Joe Biden performed so
poorly in Iowa New Hampshire and Nevada
that's what he meant by miss handling so
Biden's campaign to seize whatever
momentum comes from budda judges exit
has to get better and it has to get
better very rapidly major Mayor
Bloomberg on the ballot for the first
time tomorrow night what is at stake for
him something he knows a lot about
return on investment
he has spent more than five hundred
million dollars when you look at
broadcast and digital advertising does
he win a single state if not does he
come in a strong and respectable second
at any key battleground state and does
he reap delegates from places and an
unexpected terrain if the answer to all
three of those questions is no then
there is almost no return on investment
and no path to make this campaign
relevant going forward so all this money
and this entire premise about skipping
the first four contests is on the line
and the theory behind it will be decided
not by Mike Bloomberg and not by his
money but by voters who've been besieged
by his campaign ads and rendering their
own judgment major more than a third of
all the delegates up for grabs this
primary season will be on the plate on
Tuesday so what else should we looking
for but one thing to think about that's
a lot of Delegates but because Democrats
apportion them
not winner-take-all but how you do in
congressional districts and statewide if
you meet that 15 percent threshold your
name is Elizabeth Warren or Amy
Klobuchar or anyone else you get a few
delegates so what to watch California
Texas they're the biggest prizes but
also Democrats who can be very focused
on who can carry a place like North
Carolina and Virginia there's a lot to
watch 14 states tomorrow but remember no
one is going to emerge from Super
Tuesday with a lock on the nomination
you can get a lot closer but you will
not lock it up tomorrow night all right
major thank you very much